in a historic district in pasadena
california bounded by a domino's pizza
on one corner and a 7-eleven on the
other you'll find heaven bungalow heaven
this type of house the bungalow and
particularly the craftsman bungalow is
now celebrated in historic districts
from raleigh north carolina to seattle
washington
but the craftsman bungalow only became a
phenomenon through the evolution of a
socialist artist's philosophy
to a mass-market factory operation
[Music]
the definition of a craftsman bungalow
is really slippery but to explain it
let's take three 1911 examples from the
american founder of the craftsman
movement gustav stickley
these bungalows are all low and wide
with roofs overhanging a porch compare
that to a queen and victorian house
common in the late 1800s the queen anne
has turrets and a wraparound porch and
all sorts of ornamentation
it was also huge and expensive
but bungalows aren't just small
you can see the difference when you
compare the shape to a new orleans
shotgun house which is small and low but
also long and skinny
the bungalow interiors feature
relatively open floor plans like this no
lawn hallways just connected spaces and
materials are hopefully natural
highlighting simple wood and stone over
artifice
an ideal craftsman interior might look
like this with built-in features like
this window seat and piano beams showing
off the materials and details like these
lanterns that hang from the ceiling
a true craftsman bungalow is simple but
well appointed built carefully with
attention to every detail and that
highlights the craftsman bungalow
paradox how did a meticulously crafted
movement become a mass movement
i'll be honest before i started this
video i kind of thought craftsman tools
is where
craftsmen came from and it is true that
they are kind of connected but it
started somewhere else entirely
these chairs are from the crystal palace
exhibition of 1851 in london it was a
massive exhibition showing off the
newest most advanced everything the arts
and crafts movement was born in response
a push to stop making these chairs and
start making ones like these cleaner
simpler poet slash artist slash textile
guy slash socialist william morris was
one of many arts and crafts figures but
he became key to the craftsman movement
in america after his death today he's
best known for his gorgeous designs like
on these playing cards i've got that
were made in some factory in china you
can get stuff with his original designs
printed on it almost anywhere uh from
playing cards to your quaint pandemic
face masks morris reacted against
industrialization and artifice that was
happening during the industrial
revolution he was in favor of
craftsmanship and beauty he inspired
gustav stickley the guy who wrote that
book of craftsman plants and made that
chair to promote the arts and crafts
movement in america with his 1900s
magazine the craftsman
the first issue was all about william
morris including his socialistic career
which united with his art in that a
workman could pursue the creation of
beauty as necessary as daily bread
craftsmen he claimed found value in the
quality of their work not as disengaged
factory employees future editions of the
craftsman promoted similarly eclectic
topics from poets to factory reform and
there was a lot of furniture since that
was stickley's background the magazine
name craftsman became the way to
identify arts and crafts in america
entire homes started to show up in the
magazine as well including in 1903 the
craftsman bungalow
how to build a bungalow noted that the
word started near the banks of the
ganges but had since been transformed to
a new architectural form
the craftsman had recommendations for
how to build it all properly
over time the magazine featured more and
more craftsman house plans including
plans for bungalows they adhered to
those arts and crafts tenets
natural materials
intentional construction and as
bungalows a low slung shape and
relatively open floor plan
stickly tied the bungalow to the
craftsman movement
and then dollar signs showed up on the
plans
craftsman and bungalow had become these
buzzwords kind of like tiny house today
and nobody controlled the brand so all
the bungalows started getting lumped
together i love these two papers by
janet orr and kim hernandez that show
how bungalows got commercialized in the
development of the seattle suburbs and
in a los angeles bungalow boom
across the country in the 1900s new
areas needed hundreds of homes stickley
himself started selling floor plans so
craftsman fans could build their own
homes with their own builders
including craftsman bungalows
originally craftsman homes came from
stickley's plans or a few other esteemed
practitioners but anybody could sell
floor plans or build houses and make a
lot of money off that style
in seattle an entrepreneur named judd
yoho judd yoho
do not trust judd yoho
judd yoho sold craftsman bungalows with
no real affiliation to the arts and
crafts movement and the creation of
beauty his goal was to turn craftsmen
into a volume business the same thing
happened down in los angeles where
practical bungalows were built by the
los angeles investment company
a real estate firm that developed land
took craftsman style and built tons of
homes with the help of a massive mill
and shops sears then a catalog company
was the amazon of the era and they
joined in they sold 70 000 kit homes
between 1908 and 1940 including a bunch
of bungalows with craftsman flare
salesmen from portland to topeka
packaged bungalow style all of which had
a similar floor plan and often a
craftsman-like style but without gustav
stickley or the philosophy of the arts
and crafts movement
by 1909 the new york times was
publishing full-blown trend pieces about
the call of the bungalow it was the
latest dream of spring poet
and real estate man
by the 1920s craftsman was such a strong
brand that sears bought the trademark in
1927
and they put it on tools
what started as a movement for a
socialist textile maker had become a
gold rush where different types of
bungalows capitalized on the craftsman
cachet
a craftsman bungalow can look like an
artistic expression of individual
mastery
or it can look like hustlers
capitalizing on a trend
but really it can look like both of
those things
and that to a lot of people
looks just like heaven
okay so there is a whole world of people
who are obsessed with these kit homes
and where they actually ended up and a
lot of those include craftsman homes i
found one blog called oklahoma houses by
mail and this woman had found the los
angeles investment company catalog that
i showed earlier in this video and then
she tracked down the location of the
house that is on the cover and you can
find it on street view today it's got a
different coat of paint but it is the
same building